we're talking three of my favorite
things couture donuts pizza i'm very
happy and what better way to the heart
than with sweets for valentine's day
here to tell us about their specialty
donuts and so much more from saint
honore is alex lourdes and steve jerome
thank you guys for being here thank you
okay alex you have become a tick tock
sensation showing everyone behind the
scenes of how you create these beautiful
donuts let's talk about what you have
planned for valentine's day okay so for
valentine's day of course we had to do
conversation hearts so
we did some funny sayings for singles
like this one blocked oh that's amazing
so we want it we didn't want to leave
anyone out so we didn't get the singles
and the more traditional love you ones
and then we obviously have to include
our couture donuts that's what we're
known for yes so we did obviously the
little teddy bear and then we turned our
famous creme brulee donut into a heart
yeah so we were talking about that
that's one of your most well popular
famous
donuts i love it nothing beats a viral
doughnut no i i can't stand here any
longer without taking a bite or touching
so
okay so everyone's obsessed with the
cracks okay you just take it right in
the middle
don't hesitate and just go for it okay
this is how alex does all right we gotta
close up
all right we'll come back to donuts in a
minute because i'm going to take a bite
but i want to talk about how you're a
donut shop by day and a pizza shop by
night tell us all about it this is
smelling good yes so during obviously
pandemic we had a need obviously there
was a need for
people who wanted pizza and things at
night dinner dinner options yep we had
everything we had mixers we had burners
and things so it was a very easy
transition for us my mom comes from
southern italy a lot of those family
recipes things that we do all the time
you know true to what we always do it's
always an emphasis on quality
ingredients
san marzano tomato sauce great parmesan
cheese fresh ricotta
and you know we started it we open every
night at um
five o'clock we serve pizzas nightly out
of the out of the donut shop so fun yeah
it's like uh we call it pizza anonymous
you can see the branding there on the
boxes it's meant to be kind of a secret
pop-up shop um you know inside i thought
we have vegan and gluten-free options
yeah yes you have seriously something
for everyone and i love that you have
created this combo of donuts and pizza
everyone's two favorite things and i
mean you guys created cafe lola if you
didn't know they do it all they are so
creative what inspires you to just keep
going and coming up with fun creative
ideas honestly it's our customers like
they always come in and ask for new
things and obviously tick tock because
people give me all these ideas and so
it's so much fun and we just go in and
create fun stuff every single day yeah
it's all trying to keep up with the
trends absolutely and you know the the
community we always want to be a pillar
in a real you know fabric of that so you
know being able to offer unique cool fun
things emphasis on quality and you know
putting out real products um it's a
passion of ours and we're going to
continue to do it yeah you guys have
taken over the las vegas scene everyone
knows what you guys do and i'm going to
take a bite of this right now
when and where people can get their
donuts they need to do it before
valentine's day right yeah so we are
open valentine's day weekend come early
because it does get really busy and then
we are making an exception we're going
to be open on valentine's day but for
pre-order only so make sure you get your
orders in if you want to come pick up
something for valentine's day alex i
don't know if um i heard anything you
just said because i was like it wasn't
that good
you guys are awesome
and we're going to also do some fun
social media stuff with you guys after
and show more about the conversation
hearts you guys have just thought of all
of it and real quick where can people
find you i would give them the location
and hours and all that fun stuff yeah so
say honoree and pizza anonymous are
located in the same building it's on
flamingo and 2 15.
and our hours are tuesday through sunday
we open at 10 a.m and close at 9pm come
check us out for the pizza and donuts
you're going to love it we also fry
beignets fresh to order in the store
new orleans style french quarter
beignets tossed in powdered sugar and
all the info about the donuts you can
find us on social media you guys i can't
concentrate this is so amazing
all right we're just gonna keep it going
thank you guys so much mercedes